il marche il marche le long de la plage
et il y a une bouteille qui arrive
rejetée par la mer il prend la bouteille
ou la bouteille un génie qui sort il
fait tu m'as sauvé
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que tu veux
et il sort une carte de France il dit tu
vois ça c'est la France c'est mon pays
ce que j'aimerais c'est que la France ce
soit le monde entier
montre-moi la carte
génie génial je suis un génie de
deuxième catégorie tu as pas une autre
elle est très misogyne cette histoire et
tu as pas une autre vœu il fait oui il y
a pas de problème il sort la photo de sa
femme il fait regarde tu vois ce que
j'aimerais ça c'est ma femme ce que
j'aime c'est qu'elle soit comme si comme
ça comme ça comme ça et qu'elle arrête
de m'énerver dis moi la photo et regarde
la photo il fait redonne-moi la carte